handstand im schnee früher so mit zwölf
oder dreizehn da konnte ich auch
wirklich mal ein handstand ich habe das
jetzt mal gucken vielleicht
[Musik]
das klappt und jetzt bekommen wir haben
ein video hier endlich mal wieder aus
dem wunderschönen zimmer in köln
irgendwie bin ich in letzter zeit ganz
oft hier aber ich habe mir gedacht das
heutige video mache ich auf jeden fall
mal wieder aus dieser wunderschönen
perspektive hier finde ich eigentlich
richtig leid und ich verstehe gar nicht
wieso ich manchmal stehe aber darum soll
es wird gar nicht gehen und zwar bin ich
gestern auf diese idee gekommen
ich habe jetzt in letzter zeit als
zeugnis wollen euch angeschaut und ich
finde sowas eigentlich echt interessant
man ist ja auch wichtig dass ich mich
jetzt youtuber dafür interessieren wie
ihr alle so tickt was sie in der schule
so macht und so weiter
ich war kurz gefasst ich habe mir für
heute überlegt ich schaue mir einfach
mal eure whatsapp profilbilder an und
zwar weg ins nicht man hat langeweile
ist ein bisschen am quad unterwegs und
schaut einfach so bei den anderen leuten
den status anschaut das profilbild an
also ich glaube als natural und
instagram man nicht diesen hype hatten
da war wirklich jeder sehr sehr gerne
auch lotte unterwegs und hat geschaut
was haben meine freunde für ein
profilbild hat die person noch das
herzchen im status halt so weiter und
ich hab euch halt ganz einfach auf
snapshot und entwicklung aufgefordert
schickt mir gerne zu allerdings geht
denn auch davon aus dass ihr im video
landet ich habe wirklich eine menge
wasser profilbilder bekommen wir schauen
jetzt mal ich bin gespannt was gibt es
auf jeden fall nicht auf youtube also
wenn ihr noch ein paar haben wollt
lassen um nach oben da bei 10.000 likes
gibt es noch einen zweiten profi über
können die mir gern zu schicken bei
instagram wlan schon wieder viel zu
lange und fangen an mit dem ersten foto
und das kommt von the voice auf so gut
wie als mädchen derzeit weiß sie nicht
einfach alle fotos die wir geschickt hat
drüber gezogen auf meinem macbook und
die haben wir jetzt
the voice of my generation weiß ich
dachte gerade das wäre wohl auch
germanwatch
aber das kann ja nicht sein oder
vielleicht schon sehr gut ob die jetzt
wirklich singen kannst weiß ich nicht
ist auf jeden fall ein hübsches bild wir
beide sind bestimmt beste freundinnen
sehr interessant also schöne grüße gehen
raus an euch und wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten mädchen und das setzt
anscheinend gerne in der freizeit
einfach mal im wald auf irgendein baum
der wahrscheinlich von irgendeinem orkan
um gewählt wurde
geil also der hintergrund sieht auf
jeden fall
hat mitgenommen aus als wäre dann
wirklich so ein krasser sturm durch den
wald geschickt aber darauf wird bei
diesem foto gar nicht der fokus gelegt
daher legt ganz eindeutig bei den
mädchen im vordergrund an sich gefällt
mir das bild schon durch finde da gehört
auf jeden fall noch so einen filter
drauf um das so ein bisschen wärmer zu
machen ich übernehme das mal kurz für
dich so und jetzt kannst du das bild
screenshot und hast dann gleich so viel
fröhlichere spot profilbild gerne okay
auf diesem foto sehen wir unten einmal
stadtteil mit kopfhörer und käppi links
dahinter wenn die rechts dahinter
dorthin sind drei beste freundinnen
haben sich gedacht ich komm wir machen
jetzt mal ein richtig geiles bild da hat
jeder ganz einfach mal den handy blitz
aktiviert und schonte hat das foto
geknipst
geil obwohl kann man ja eigentlich gar
nicht sagen wer das foto jetzt gemacht
hat ist auf jeden fall ein cooles bild
schöne grüße an euch und das war
natürlich nicht so gemeint so willkommen
zum nächsten bild und zwar aa also hier
muss ich wirklich sagen leute um das
schon mal vorweg zu nehmen ich finde so
diese fotos auf bahngleisen sind auch
schon echt mega ausgelutscht aber
wirklich ihr müsst doch nicht auf
irgendwelche bahngleise gehen um fotos
zu machen da sind schon recht viele
unfälle passiert auch in deutschland
unseren ece ist dann gerne auch mal
schneller da ist sie gucken könnte außer
die deutsche bahn hat mal wieder
verspätung aber manchmal kommen die auch
pünktlich war sehr selten deswegen fahre
ich auch keine bahn mehr
schöne grüße und jetzt frage ich mich
gerade ist das bildbearbeitung oder
haben die wirklichen der lichterkette
mitgenommen es ist auf jeden fall ein
schönes foto aber das kann man auch
woanders machen also auf den bahngleisen
so wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
foto und hier sehen wir das gibt's ja
gar nicht kurze frage an euch wer auf
diesem foto kommt euch bekannt vor
drei sekunden zeit zu überlegen schreibe
es in die kommentare
richtig wir hatten ja letztens karneval
und der footballspieler in der mitte das
bin ich
man erkennt mich echt nicht mehr und
mehr im hintergrund denkt sich nur so
high und jetzt muss ich wirklich mal
sagen ich finde das echt schade dass ich
der einzige bin auf dem foto also
zumindest von den mädels vorne der sich
verkleidet hat okay gut das mädchen ganz
rechts geht als katze und die anderen
gehen
okay gut ich nehme alles zurück die
anderen drei gehe natürlich als alex wie
community
wer hätte das anders erwartet also
schöne grüße auch nochmal an euch ist
ein cooles foto geworden danke dass ihr
mir das geschickt habe und wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten bild ja hier
haben wir die jsa glaube ich schönes
foto gefällt mir ich da muss jetzt will
ich auch mal sagen echt hübsch schön
bearbeitet geiles bild also hier auch
schöne grüße und wir schauen aber weiter
selbst wenn alles zerbricht scherben
spiegeln das licht schöner spruch das
war es dann auch so und jetzt kommen wir
die pärchen fotos wir haben ja einmal
den ich werde hieß es
ich habe echt wirklich eine menge
pärchen fotos bekommen irgendwie war
gefühlt jedes zweite bild ein pärchen
foto hass auf jeden fall eine hübsche
freundin marcel ich wünsche euch viel
glück und dort hält bestimmt auch ganz
ganz lang und das gleiche wünsche ich
auch den beiden hier ich weiß ja nicht
mal wie die person heißt mir das foto
geschickt hat aber wir klickt mal weiter
durch und sehen hier sogar handstand im
schnee mit 1213 da konnte ich auch
wirklich mal ein handstand ich habe das
jetzt mal gucken vielleicht nicht immer
[Musik]
ohne wird das war ja gar nicht so
schlecht vor allem wenn man dann genauso
wie die person hier einfach kurz so
einen snapshot macht eigentlich gar
keine handschellen kann wenn man es zum
passt im augenblick trifft sie zuerst
habe ich dir überführt und spart
vielleicht kannst du wirklich anstand so
leute und hier sehen wir noch ein
dieses bild das ist traumhaft da hat
jemand zugeschlagen beim merge ist in
der video beschreibung natürlich
verlinkt wenn ihr auch so eine schöne
beutel haben wollt oder ein schönes t
shirt dann tor vorbei das waren jetzt
einige wurzel profilbilder hat mich
wirklich sehr unterhalten ich bin
gespannt auf weitere boxer profilbilder
schickt mir die aber auch bitte nur zu
wenn sie witzig sind so standardmäßig
mit einem slapshot filter habe ich auch
in massen bekommen heute aber aber das
ist ja irgendwie nichts besonderes also
leute ich hoffe dass wieder
durchgefallen hast doch nach oben dafür
zweiten part 10.000 likes sind drin und
wir sehen uns auf snapshot oder
instagram schotter vorbei
bis morgen